je sais quel est cet endroit
[Musique]
les gardiens du temps sont les rois du
cirque
et les clones y jouent leur rôle à la
perfection
des métaphores en pagaille c'est
magnifique ça vous donne l'heure encore
plus malin je suis mme alors oui je sais
ok ok
signé pour valider tout ce que vous avez
dit dans votre vie c'est absurde
y compris ça
[Musique]
nous protège ou la fluidité
en ramassant le tesseract vous avez
altérer la réalité
je veux que vous nous aidiez à y
remédier
pourquoi moi il se trouve que le point
de vue de l'eau qui est inimitable
j'aurai une arme
vous croyez vraiment en se mariant loki
forte heureusement ils croyaient en lui
même pour nos 2
je suis très touché
que vous sembliez vous imaginez pouvoir
le manipuler
city longueur d'avancé sur nous
la confiance n'est pas votre point fort
ne se passe
vous pouvez me faire confiance l'eau qui
j'ai passé en revue le moindre moment de
votre vie passée vous avez littéralement
trahi vos semblables chaque fois que
c'était possible
je n'ai qu'à pas recommencer
on
vient juste d'atterrir on a toujours le
feu vert l'opération est en route
on parachute en commande au secret de
robots dans un pays où on n'a absolument
rien à faire c'est sérieux depuis la
seconde où ils atterrissent
tu la fermes par evo ou je vous dis à
tous
[Applaudissements]
en avant pour elle
ces gens entrevue faites-les tous
disparaître nous ne voulons aucun témoin
on a son identité je vous envoie ça un
marine si c'est un déserteur ça pourrait
être un très bon test je me suis dit la
même chose
elle est étudiante en médecine ce sont
tous des médecins ils sont là en mission
humanitaire
allez ça suffit là tu es en train de lui
[ __ ] la trouille et tu me fout la
trouille à moi aussi j'ai pas la
trouille
là
nyala t'attends tu veux pas que ma vraie
âme situe aux
[Applaudissements]
alors
fabriqué par les humains pour infliger
la marque aussi leurs idées dans les
différents je suis un homme suive en
tête une machine
vous ne savez pas tout de moi
j'ai vécu des tas de vie
[Musique]
avant d'être une avenger
avant d'avoir cette famille
j'ai accumulé les erreurs en choisissant
entre ce que le monde attend de nous
et c'est que nous sommes
[Musique]
il faut pourtant là où tout a commencé
et où tu crois que j'étais pendant tout
ce temps
on a un travail à terminer
tous est têtue vous êtes les filles les
plus durs au monde
excuse moi j'aime
nous avons suivi les ordres et nous
avons joué notre rôle et pas réel
si ténu elle pour moi
[Musique]
tu étais vraiment vieux
à toi de jouer
au boulot
saturent
oui maman
je
une chose est sûre
je ne fuirai plus m'en passer
[Musique]
vous deviez signé mon ordre de
libération monsieur il ya trois mois
maintenant je décide quand tu parais
quand tu restes
et
quand même un bon
non
clermont debout chéri
[Musique]
or monsieur l'époque
j'ai commandé un récital à notre petit
roi s'ignorent elle sépare tiennent
enfin elle est ma propriété alors je
fais ce que je veux hôtel
cette fille que vous avez violé dont
vous avez assassiné la famille
cette fille est morte
et on ne peut pas tuer ceux qui y est
déjà mort
si je retrouvais les blancs ceux qui ont
massacré ma famille j'agirai comme toi
je t'aiderai à voir si sa main
[Musique]
tu as vu
mademoiselle billie holiday
alami
aussi on vous aime moi
lan a assez paix dit que billie holiday
ella voix de notre peuple on devrait
intégrer d'autres personnes dans le
public ça changerait la donne d'avoir
des noirs et des blancs à science ans
laquelle de mes chansons préférées vous
struyf roth ouais parle de chose
importante cette chanson de choses qui
se passent dans le pays
cette co leader mais de mauvaises idées
dans le g des jo elle encourage la
colère et les revendications du peuple
noir ces paroles sont provocatrice vous
avez un plan c'est une toxicomane
exactement
sa femme lui
sortait la scène death by
[Musique]
me laisse plus chanter nulle part plus
de clubs plus de pognon plus rien
tu es comme un marteau qui revenu pour
frapper plus fort
elle a réussi à devenir quelqu'un vous
ne le supportez pas parce qu'elle est
forte belle et loire
suis je
[Musique]
ap le puits
vous pensez que je vais renoncer à
chanter cette chanson aux petits enfants
chanteront foule
la chroniqueuse femmes comme gut a écrit
cette semaine les messages haineux et
les menaces de mort à mon encontre
devrait appartenir au passé
twitter facebook tous les commentaires
sur les réseaux tout ça ça peut être
brutal on pourrait pas avoir des
opinions différentes
sans pour autant être gros si tu aurais
dû parler du livre nous savons même pas
son garde du livre parce que tu n'as pas
tout à fait terminée chéris ton livre tu
devrais peut-être lecorcier un petit peu
tu vois ce que je veux dit le corset oui
le corset je veux la première partie
dans une semaine par mail hockey
ne jamais lire les commentaires je sais
[Applaudissements]
je propose comment pall comme une
brochette cette chine de luxe et qu'on
la fasse brûler à feu doux sur la plage
vraiment très classe chienne de luxe
merci beaucoup ça m'a pris un peu de
temps pour le trouver puis corsé
tu es encore aller sur twitter c'est ça
j'ai juste besoin de prendre un peu
l'air
[Musique]
mais tu sais que j'ai aussi un exutoire
l'hôtel
[Musique]
gentil
nous ne voyons pas avoir des divergences
d'opinion sans avoir à se taper dessus
tu as appelé la mauvaise [ __ ] de
[ __ ] [ __ ] de [ __ ]
peu importe ce que c'est
tu peux tout me dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
buvant à la vie
[Musique]
un paquet pour toi
que tout le monde sorte
écoutez moi
[Musique]
bonjour lieutenant banks
savez vous où sont vos collègues
policiers
gilles saux
je croyais que jx au était mort c'est le
gars
[Musique]
prophétique t'as pas une seconde à terre
comment je vais le point c'est si je
peux faire confiance à personne dans
cette [ __ ] brigade tu n'y arriveras
pas seul
celui qui a fait ça une autre motivation
c'est plus personnel
c'est quand la dernière fois que tu as
vu ton père
[Musique]
un imitateur de jx oh ça va pas être
facile
[Musique]
mais c'est juste une diversion pour agir
tranquille dans le commissariat
je veux tout le monde sur cette affaire
il peut être n'importe ans ça peut être
n'importe qui
on va retourner toute la ville
bonjour lieutenant banks
quelle est la dernière fois où vous avez
vu votre père
[Musique]
tu
as 12 ans
[Musique]
des
corrections
et
marc
ferret
[Musique]
fabrice
gare
tu veux me aimé
[Musique]
lapointe
moi ma vie en l'air
on utilise par la flèche
[Musique]
c'est quoi
ce sens également disparu
[Musique]
en 2016
enfin le rebond du baril qui avant de
passe
des hélicoptères
bizarre
l'éducatrice
tu
[Musique]